[Music]
[Applause]
all right
welcome back to the Breakthrough it's
our daily livestream that keeps you
updated on on all the nerdy news you
need to know right here from our very
own break room live in a Secret
locations
don't do it don't do it uh coming up on
today's show we're talking about
Cameron's true enchanting Cruel
Intentions some true cruel attention hey
why are the russos being so secretive
what do we got to hide secret was there
a third Russo who's dead and we got some
updates on June two ah yes
I'm joined today by an amazing cast as
always we got Tommy Bechtel hey and you
know what I'm gonna use this time for
twofold oh boy things one happy birthday
Bryce I told you I'd wish you a happy
birthday and I did happy belated hope
you ate so much cake that your jeans
didn't fit today secondly the break room
is now on Tick Tock baby that's right at
the underscore break room we are on Tick
Tock apologies for my hair I don't know
what's going on Jessica massacred me
here you can see I have two different
sideburns I have been living my life
like this I went into CVS they asked me
to leave all right the first person ever
kicked out of this evening that's right
there was a man just drinking drinking
schnapps in the middle of the CVS he got
to stay now the breaker was now on Tick
Tock can you just scroll that little
party boy no follow us for even more
break room content and we've noticed how
much love you you've all how much love
how much you are okay say we notice how
much you guys all love isolating clips
of the show especially on our Discord
and we do appreciate that so we've
decided let's make it into a contest
throughout the week we want you to
submit your favorite break room Clips in
our Discord and at the end of the week
we will play our favorite clip of the
week as we close out our Friday show hit
that exclamation point clips for more
info on this contest keep clipping baby
keep clipping and no tripping no
tripping uh we also have Jessica Clemens
no it's okay give us a half hour
but thank you oh okay that's it yeah I
don't know I don't know what to say it's
beautiful and Erica Russo is here as
well hello hi hey reporting live from
the Dark Side of the Moon that's where
the studio is yeah oh yes yes hidden on
the the Burbank side yeah just near the
Zankou Chicken
yeah uh yeah submit those clips on the
Discord there's a whole uh uh chat slack
for it I don't know how Discord works
I'm an old man you just have to be 18
plus to join our district that's right
you got to be above 18. real quick if I
can camera before
on me you got me the red light's not on
so I get nervous that's nice it's not on
me can I have camera four please I'm
gonna give it to you John how much what
are you eating a salad what's going on
uh I want to apologize for the
introduction of the host I panicked I
saw the teleprompter said Tommy pitched
The Tick Tock and I I just went on and
we really should just introduced
everyone and then I could have talked
about the tick tock and it would have
been normal but now what happened was I
was distracted because I was thinking
about how undeserving our audience is
that we even have a tick tock your trash
bags your garbage people you haven't
given a dollar yet for this show okay
the super chance at zero for this week
guess what we're gonna be doing some
redemptions and I better see some money
in there our Uncle T is going to be
pretty upset okay back to the show and
if you are marveling at Tommy's hair
today if you weren't around last week I
don't know where you were uh but uh we
did a little special Redemption Tommy
got a haircut live on the show courtesy
of Jessica who I think did a great job
oh yes a lot of quality very good good
stuff uh that's the kind of wackiness
that could happen here on the break room
and today we've got a whole new channel
Redemption for you someone called it a
brock a brohawk that's a pretty good
brohawk I like it uh uh for today's
Redemption and I'm frightened about it
uh we're doing the Chubby Bunny
confession Challenge and not to put any
weight issues on our rabbit friends uh
if you're not familiar with the game
Chubby Bunny you try to choke yourself
to death and that's what we're gonna do
to hear today on the break room for you
people for every hundred dollars you get
have through super chats or what have
you one of us will confess to a past
misdeed deep deep from the darkest
regions of our life uh well just popping
marshmallows in our mouth to see
we'll push the limits of our trachea to
God knows what yeah I really hope we
survive I've been called the throat goat
before so let's see if I can live right
that even means
the projects are already rolling in
Google Chrome
no please whatever you do do not do not
do that uh so that is our our chat rate
episode uh for today are we doing
anything crazy for the week uh I
actually have a pretty exciting
announcement again and I promise to make
this a little briefer uh I have gotten
permission from my break rumors my break
homies my breakies my roomies if we pass
a thousand dollars total this week so we
have a stretch goal okay a thousand
dollars they will let me turn Monday the
day after Comic-Con ends into tomican
that's right the break room will be
transformed into tomicon there will be
panels guests cosplay announcements and
I'll tell you this if we get to a
thousand I'll do a Time account and
it'll be fine but every dollar over a
thousand I'm gonna go bigger I'm talking
I will bring actual celebrities in here
so I will go out of pocket my personal
no money for exclusives we'll send away
things to Winners I will have merch
there'll be merch announcements if we
raise more money but if you landed just
on a thousand I'm still going to give
you a good experience I'm like a call
girl okay for a thousand you're still
gonna have a good time 1500 I'll take
you to heaven no kissing though no
kissing on the mouth you said the word
Comic-Con and Jessica literally died
like inside and out that's right Jessica
doesn't like it it's no problem we've
already established that I don't like
him a Convention of Tommy would be so
mean to me
that's funny because I have actually our
first announcement our first panel
atomicon is a showcase called the
celebration of Jessica Clemens it is a
three minute video montage that I have
already started working on about uh all
that Jessica does for me as a friend and
as a host on this show so that's our
first announcement uh if the show if we
greenlit Comic-Con there will be a panel
called a celebration of Jessica Clements
I realize that sounds like a wake
[Laughter]
yeah and if you want to look like
Jessica today check out new
rockstarsmerch.com where you can get all
our great merch options but we don't
have time to talk about merch we gotta
talk about headlines
first headline and this one sounds like
something from an ad-lib uh deadline is
reporting that Peter Dinklage is set to
join the growing Ensemble of lion Gates
lion lions gates Hunger Games prequel
Hunger Games The Ballad of songbirds and
snakes Dinklage will play casca high
bottom dean of the academy like I said
it sounds like a word mishmash salad
come on we all know Costco High bottom
dean of the academy do you think this is
gonna revive The Hunger Games I mean the
cast is pretty good the guy I think they
have the girl from uh West Side Story
isn't it like there's I saw there which
girl uh Rachel Ziegler who said Rachel
Maddow Rachel Maddow yes and by the way
everyone in the chat saying this isn't a
real Mohawk do you understand how much
crap I put in my hair together we tried
to get it we tried so much this is what
it looks like naturally okay this is
what's happening I'm like Willie at the
end of freeway I'm sad I'm in captivity
my dorsal fin has flopped Jessica tried
her best she cut my hair with a beard
trimmer listen I tried we tried it's not
a great Mohawk I understand it's it's
standing up on its own do you understand
I have to live my life like this now so
please for all of you complaining that
you got griftied about the Mohawk I got
grifted by this faux hawk next headline
hey June's Twitter feed has confirmed
that production on Dune 2 has officially
begun let's get excited you rude duners
out there it's happening we're gonna see
more sand worms more other Dune stuff I
can't I didn't read the book you said
other dude I bet you they'll be sand for
a month there when doing June was out
and I was reading all about it I knew
everything and now I've forgotten
completely everything about that story
uh but I am super excited for the next
dude yeah I can't wait for the new Dune
uh Dunes cruise control yeah yeah yeah
it's gonna be great I'm shocked that
production is just now starting I mean I
know it was in Greenland until like
January but it's like I thought they'd
be ready to go I looked at his hair and
it's just so funny I'm sorry Barry
Clemens are you related to a Perry
Clemens I'm not okay yeah I just thought
all dancers were related
next headline in a casting exclusive
Rafael Casal from blind spotting is set
for a major role in the upcoming second
season of Disney pluses Marvel series
Loki this is coming from deadline a rep
for Marvel declined a comment shocking
uh but word of Castle's casting started
trickling out when a photo from the set
of season two leagues online uh it
features Castle walking alongside Tom
heidelson and Owen Wilson walking
confirmed in Loki season two exciting
in with Wilson
walk in right before the green lit Dune
two walk in with Wilson do you really
feel the way I do camera four thank you
next headline buried in an article about
Disney pluses 2023 MCU slate is the
Revelation at secret Invasion will debut
sometime in 2023. but when I thought we
already knew that I didn't I guess
that's what that I thought that that had
been said in one of their weird Graphics
they put out I was pretty sure they said
it I guess there's this it's still set
for 2023. good news great secrets around
this even in the title I mean
everything's going to change we're not
going to trust anybody anymore here's
your next headline uh Josh Horowitz
tweeted out a video confirming that the
Russo brothers are not directing Secret
Wars or at least they haven't had any
discussions about it which I do not
believe at all
you don't think that the Russo Brothers
had at least one discussion at Marvel
about Secret Wars they already talked
about it it's not about wanting to do it
but they did a great job no well did
they bring it up yes and also what does
Marvel do time and time again lie they
always say like oh I'm not going to be
in this movie and then they appear
inside the movie uh Liam Neeson did it
uh Kang did it uh Andrew Garfield did it
Toby did everybody's there everybody's
done it I think they're gonna they're
gonna try to touch it also it's like I
don't want to see Secret Wars done by
honestly anyone else because I do want
to be a two-parter movie they do good
two-parters they're really good at
making sure everything is accomplished
they're gonna I mean I think it's gonna
be more than a two-parter movie yeah we
talked about this too everyone in the
chat said over two and I was like I've
never seen a three
part Marvel movie well like I have but
like Marvel movie if we're gonna would
you yeah like all the event all the
Avengers you would count you would count
I guess there's just so many in between
that I could I count them as singles
yeah so but this seems like it would
come one right after the other yeah yeah
so that's the part where I'm like
oh three parts three hours each probably
yeah yeah it's more of the Rings all
over I guess yeah yeah and I'm excited
for this Trilogy oh yeah so many
superheroes so many super villains
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's Monday I feel the energy in here we
gotta fill the room guys they need us
everyone's trying to wake up on this
Monday we're all trying to turn up hey
let's get excited once we hit that
chubby bunny I'm gonna chub the bus
there's a real Calm before the storm
feeling here right like we're all afraid
of choking it down if you guys want to
see me choke to death right now guys get
60 bucks so we can choke Jessica okay on
camera for the first time oh my gosh oh
my gosh uh we ran a poll asking if you
think secretary
all right
we're right up Paul asking do you think
Secret Wars works better as a Disney
plus series or movie 61 said movie I
think I think we would all agree with
that because so far all the series not
even just marvel series but even like
the Star Wars series they don't feel
like a movie yeah right they don't have
the moviness of it yeah there's always a
part where you're like ah this is a TV
show yeah wait a second
yeah
I recognize that set from the universal
back line like what's going on here's
the shirt from Jaws come on guys we want
the real movie stuff uh Miss Marvel's
wrist shot gave an interview to The
Hollywood Reporter in which he insisted
that his character Camron had pure
intentions on the show of course you
would say this he said quote as far as
I'm aware he was never duping her this
is Camron speaking about
Kamala he was never trying to play
kamawa and prior to some of the changes
that were made later on in the script
and during the reshoots was probably
probably a bit clearer but in my mind
that was always the case so this is kind
of him saying that like
and no point was he trying to duper he's
he's blaming his mom first yeah it
sounds like I mean that's what I've done
for 38 years just blame your mom for it
there you go why can't you commit I got
mommy issues but this is what someone
would say if they were duping someone
then that's true they're not going to
give it away wait a second are you
saying this is this is an incept to do
this is a double dupe we're being double
Duke we're being double dude
I was gonna say this is the scoop on the
double dupe the scoop of the new what
does my mom say she says you got the
okie doke oh yeah
my mom says you got the okie doke I'm
like damn I say okey dokey artichokie I
made it white
white appropriation
that's that's a problem that's a problem
and finally according to the Marvel's
updates on Twitter Miss Marvel
director's ideal Arby and belafala
revealed that the finale's post-credits
scene the one where we saw Carol Pierre
in the closet swap places that was
actually shot by the Marvel's director
Nia DeCosta uh which is very interesting
probably because she's there she's
working with uh uh uh the actress at the
time they must have gone on the set I
think I think that's a secret backdoor
confirmation that the Khan family and
their house is a location in that film
oh okay so I think we could have guessed
it yeah I guess but I think that makes
me all the more confident we're getting
more Papa con who is mine I hope so
absolutely
That's funny though just even thinking
about it like that scene did look a
little if the room did look a little
different there was it was so much I
might be completely wrong but I did when
as soon as I saw Carol Danver show up I
was like there wasn't that much Carol
Danvers in that room there was like I
don't know like the hey they had the
hair yeah from Seven where she was just
obsessed with her yes lack of hair blood
the Pepe Silvia they like they had it
everywhere
um but I might go back and look at it
because I remember being like I was like
she had a lot of Avenger stuff not only
Carol Danvers everywhere either way dude
dude dude I'm gonna say okay I'll say it
and then I'll say it okay in a recent
interview with the Empire Miss Marvel
producer Sarah Amina Amana details how
they've been wanting to connect Kamala
to being a mutant since 2012 to 2013. I
was in high school then saying we
originally wanted to make her a music
it wasn't a flex I was just like damn
that was ages ago I was in high school
too but I was 30
wait for chubby bunny
60 more dollars
like after you made that show and all my
money drinking over the weekend thank
you John Lee for your courage to give
4.99 thank you okay well in 2012 and
2013 then saying we originally wanted to
make her a mutant that was the whole
intention to be able to do that in the
series they were able to get back to
that initial idea so it had me wondering
after watching boss's breakdown and
thinking about it I'm not saying this is
what I want you guys don't get mad at me
do you think we've been we've been
asking for X-Men we've been asking for
X-Men but we're seeing only mutation is
there likely a chance we won't get the
X-Men but we'll get the Marvel
characters announced as mutants like
Kamala so going forward any new kind of
character even Monica maybe we're just
gonna say they're the mutants but we're
not going to get the like the like false
capital x yes I don't think we need
a Charles xavier-led team of
extraordinarily gifted youth for like
six more years I'm fine with having
mutants slowly emerge into the MCU
without it being like it's X-Men again
right like it's like we can have the
let's build towards the X-Men let's have
phase eight be the X-Men you know like
why do we gotta have the X-Men right
away just because we own them you know
it's like when you buy a box of baseball
cards in the pack you don't need to rip
all the packs open all at once Savor
them Savor those X-Men keep Gambit
sealed up for a while Jim mint Gambit
sealed up and put it in your closet and
sell it on eBay when you need rent money
or you're starving for booze in that
order yeah yeah I well I mean I'm
completely fine with getting X-Men
eventually it just seems like the
bracket for how the movies are going
we're probably going to touch on Young
Avengers before we do that so I think
it's gonna be more than six years but I
think when people were stuck on at the
San Diego I think it was San Diego
Comic-Con where Kevin feige was like
mutants uh they were like and it was
like no because it is hard to have the
mutants without the X-Men they're
everywhere yes 90 of the populations
like escort into the mutant world is
through the X-Men right and I mean the
X-Men is a wide array of mutants yeah
the team has changed as much as The
Avengers has over the years yeah well if
our my theory is correct that means we
wouldn't see your Jubilee and we went
Jubilee will be the second mutant
don't worry my plan Jubilee's still
there she's just not being she hasn't
been rescued by Charles yet she has a
knee rescue that's right it's powerful I
feel like and also because there's also
that a little detail that like oh well
Deadpool's coming but Deadpool is more
like X-Force and I think they're still
trying to like decode how that's gonna
happen and um unless it's like the
incursion and he just winds up in our
universe like I it's still not X-Men and
so I'm like with people that are like
please do Jean Gray again please do this
again I just don't think we're going to
be doing it I think it's going to be a
minute and I think I said this before
too this is time for Alpha flight to
take the lead yeah let Canada leave the
right here but our Canadian Brothers the
Canadian X-Men let them be in charge
Wolverine was on Alpha flight Captain
Canada right isn't that the one the
Sasquatch is on there uh uh North Stars
on there
Alpha fight we're in good hands with
Alpha flight okay Canadians are much
more welcoming than some of our American
neighbors we just don't like to say it
out loud right I mean you bring up
X-Force is interesting because that
could be a way but we already did it
yeah you think they would want to do it
again for the Disney they want to do it
right this time
well I think I liked it because I loved
Domino right and I loved what they did
with that oh yeah she was great I mean I
I think they're gonna say all that stuff
separate different universes
that's actually a Spiderman in that
universe
I mean I would say that like modern
audiences right most of them are
familiar with the X-Men based on like
the 90s Claremont run whether it's
through the comic books or through the
very popular show which they're
rebooting to do Expo 97. you know if you
go back and you read the old old X-Men
stuff it's a little silly little goofy
little little Golden Age Silver age
Shenanigans going on uh but one thing
you always had with them with the
mutants even when like mutants were like
coming being made aware to the public
was there was always like a history
involved well I would really like the
MCU to do is be like no there haven't
really been mutants uh we kind of talked
about this last week like let's meet a
young Charles Xavier now a young Magneto
now not like they've been around in the
background for 16. they're just getting
started just glad it just started
happening now but you bring up a good
point that we might not have the X-Men
for like a very long time I don't think
we're gonna get it for a long time what
my original theory was was how uh when
koi was on earlier he brought up this
situation I think everyone knows is that
like X-Men was uh a reflection to like
civil rights and people that are just
minorities and being oppressed and they
completely are and I think that would be
if we want to translate that to today we
should be taking it from like Monica and
uh Kamala who are brown girls from uh
New Jersey a brown girl is dealing with
so much so I think like that reflects
more from these MCU characters or Marvel
characters than it does with the old
X-Men because unfortunately the old
X-Men
um were a lot of white people uh so it's
in the movies in the movies so I think
when you want I think they're also
keeping that in mind that's like hey if
it mimics this we have like Watchmen on
HBO that deals with it we have Lovecraft
country that deals with it these shows
were top are very topical I think to do
that you have to pull from what we
already have in the Marvel uh universe
and the Marvel Comics which is like
get the actual people that are oppressed
in like like in the show and put them
into the X-Men Gene but that that was
originally what I was thinking when I
came up with this I don't want anyone
yelling at me
um do you guys think that they'll just
declare in humans and mutants the same
thing
I we have discussed this on a number of
panel shows on this channel recently I
feel like or at least one
and I don't I I go back to this point
that I I don't know why I look at you
Brandon because you look at me
uh I think it goes back to the almighty
dollar there is money to be made in
humans there's money to be made in
mutants if you keep them separate you
can make two different properties you
can sell two different kinds of toys you
can sell two different kinds of comic
books you can sell two different kinds
of advertising on two different kinds of
movies and it's Twice As Nice
uh I think that's a good deal yeah
that's a good deal baby I take that deal
Selena are throwing something in the
chat which I think is interesting they
say I bring I say bring aim bring like
can I bring back the idea
it's Advanced idea mechanics or whatever
we're talking about the yellow yeah yeah
the yellow the Modoc world right uh we
had we had a little teas of nine Iron
Man three it wasn't uh was it isn't uh
Moon Knight the guy Richard what's his
name was it he affiliated with aim oh am
I making something else
ah thank you anyways thanks Jesus aim
and having like yeah maybe they're
involved somehow maybe they're involved
yeah the idea that mutants and in humans
are somehow linked in a weird way maybe
there there were in human experiments
done by the cree hundreds of years ago
and that laid the foundation for the
mutations that we're seeing now they've
been buried in our genetic code
something crazy like that or yeah have
the Inhumans and mutants fight have have
the world say we'll only take one of you
would you kill each other would you
prefer them to be two separate things or
do you because there's a difference
between like I prefer this and what's
easier for the Marvel cinematics I get
what you're saying and like in this
world where Disney is making shows and
movies you can have both and I think
this idea is it can exist in the comics
because there's so much and it's so
spread out when when you look at the
fact that like they are only able to
tell stories through screen time and
that's very limited when you add it all
up it might be confusing but they don't
appear to be afraid to confuse people no
because they keep bringing up these
ideas in every movie and every show that
are similar but like a touch to the side
like this whole noise dimension thing
yeah it's like yet another dimension
another weird kind of thing we've had to
kind of slap our heads around isn't that
kind of the dirty secret of comics in
general is that everything is basically
a riff on something else that has become
popular like DC and Marvel did it
through each other for years it would
come out with this character right DC
would have this character then Marvel
would create this character as a as a
direct competition to like you know or
kind of a play on it and it's basically
copyright infringement but it's not
because you make them a different color
suit and a slightly different Power set
it's like an even inside of the comic
book uh labels in Marvel and DC they rip
each other off because there's they're
not all written by the same person yeah
you know in the beginning when they were
you know it was Kirby and Stan Lee but
now it's like there's thousands of
people who write Comics so of course
there's going to be some some uh you
know slightly similar things and
inevitably make refusing to watch oh my
gosh sorry what were you saying I said
no thanks yeah I also think they they
lay a lot of these terms and introduce
these new Concepts to kind of give
themselves outs right and you know just
kind of lady the Gin the Nord Dimension
ancestral plane yeah Sandy place the
Moon Knight drove in the boat sandy
beaches yeah like they're these all all
things that they're like we introduced
it so if we needed to you know jump out
of a hole we can go back and revisit
that yeah I think we can just I I think
what to expect maybe not but this is
what I believe in is that they're gonna
start bringing in more characters for
the Marvel Cinematic Universe call them
mutants or even take they could what
they could do is take people that are
technically mutants like Squirrel Girl
and throw her in and we could just be
like oh yeah because she's new to both
like she wasn't in the X-Men franchise
and she wasn't in this so we can just
bring her in so maybe there are X-Men
characters that we didn't see in X-Men
that can show up in the MCU and that'd
be cool and there'll be mutants but more
I think they're just gonna keep bringing
out people people that are already in
the MCU and be like they're mutants like
Monica will be the next one Monica will
be just like oh uh this is
I think they'll try and say someone like
Clint Barton or Kate Bishop when like
they weren't ever in the comics what
does Kate do that would Warner
perfect aim oh yeah just like
consistently like Clint and Natasha
they're always considered like Peak
human right like they don't have a
genetic mutation but they are operating
at Peak human they they're the best of
the best yeah yeah highly I think I
think that's where it's gonna start
going like they're just gonna be like
popping up now and then you're like oh I
like how boss said it's like uh during
our uh Captain Marvel Captain Marvel you
don't know who's a squirrel and who's
not right so I think it's just like this
is now we're going to start noticing
there's gonna be a lot more in the MCU I
mean I just don't want the like oh
there's been a highly organized team
operating I agree it makes them those
Shadows like that's my thing with like
Fantastic Four if you're gonna say
they've been here since the 60s where
have they been like they never got
involved in anything like I don't know
about that do you think they're good
well like it's ernals yeah well but the
eternals are they're useless robots
oh yeah oh yeah um so do you think that
[Music]
um
so anyway do you think so you don't want
the mutants to just be I don't want them
to have been in the background so what
you want them to come during the
incursions or do you want them to come
during they can just start getting
mutations now but don't tell me there's
a guy with a costume he's been running
around doing stuff and no one thought to
bring it up yeah Cyclops was like yeah
wait Thanos never mind
so the powers come through when they're
going through puberty or when they're
expressed so what if it's someone that
went through puberty but never been
stressed and then they're stressed out
then just never like manifested yeah so
they come later in life everyone changes
their body's different Kamala is still
16 she's 16. yeah I don't know her age
stop looking at me like this yeah you
were saying you were saying that you
were pretty sure she's 16 right now yeah
she's getting a driver's test so she's
got to be at least 16. yeah so she it's
there's a lot of 16 year olds that are
probably just now getting their powers
or late bloomers that are like 19.
either way I'm sorry to bring this X-Men
not coming for 12 years I'll be dead
that's the truth I'll be dead by then I
also put that I I just think this is how
they're gonna confirm it for a little
bit is are they gonna do the 90s
music
yeah when does that get old no they're
gonna do it for every MCU character that
is found out when we find out the
marbles that Monica is a mutant yeah
[Laughter]
when Jubilee shows up at the arcade it
goes full this is the full song when I
was talking to people about Jubilee
there were like oh it's probably mine
when uh photography about Jubilee they
were like the girl with the fireworks
yeah yeah
I do love that they are using that
little Stinger right now because like we
don't trust them at all you have to we
never know when they're lying to us we
don't know if Bruno knows what he's
talking about he just said the word
mutation he's not he's not a scientist
he's a kid it's just got that iPad with
all the thermo stuff on it I love that
he has so much access to anything
that's a great time to talk about our
friends today at Better Health we're
gonna talk about access I want to thank
them for sponsoring the break room this
week personally I recently decided to
seek out some therapy of some stressful
news made me rethink the way I cope with
things it might not just be three pints
of ice cream life is full of twists and
turns and it's important to show up for
yourself through it all guys better help
online therapy will assess your needs
and can match you with your own licensed
professional therapist in less than 48
hours I can speak to this because I did
literally sign up for it last week and
it literally took less than 48 hours to
match me with a therapist who I now have
my first appointment with later this
week time to fix this huh we're getting
started guys It's a Long Way Rome wasn't
built a day and my brain will not be
unaffed in a long weekend I've started
to stop therapy many times with my adult
life that's true getting back Started
With Better Health it was very easy I
can't recommend it enough I am a very
lazy person if I can do it you guys can
do it trust me if I could recognize I
need a little bit of extra help and I
can go to a website and fill something
out very quickly and create a profile
but still feel like they understand
enough about me any one of you can do
this I promise you if you are struggling
and you need to talk to someone better
health is a quick and easy way to try
therapy for the first time or jump back
in those therapeutic Waters it's not a
crisis line it's not self-help it's
Professional Therapy done securely
online it's available to people
worldwide you can log into your account
anytime and send a message to your
therapist again I've already done this
it's so easy I got a quick response you
can schedule a weekly video or phone
sessions so you don't have to be on
camera if you don't want to if you're
not like me and demand to be seen if you
don't get camera ready for your therapy
with full pancake makeup and Kabuki
robes appropriating cultures that are
not your own
getting into therapy every week is as
easy there's a few clicks on your laptop
or phone and guess what you'll be
shocked here but I'm not just reading
this for my health they have a special
offer for our Breakers our roomies your
trash pandas get 10 off your first month
at betterhealth.com break room that's
right even the trash bags get 10 off
your first month online therapy at
better
h-e-l-p.com slash break room
now that may have been heavy for some of
you you may not like the fact that I was
speaking a little seriously well guess
what it's not all serious sometimes it's
fun
it's time for mandatory fun oh yeah yeah
to the mandatory fun that's right it's
the segment so nice
we only play the graphic once on Mondays
sorry I hit it again
yes
I fell for it yeah you guys fell for it
you were sleeping here again
yes all right just three we gotta build
to something this week okay it can't all
be about me 20 more dollars till we get
Jessica shoving marshmallows in here but
Jessica wants to play Chubby Bunny fans
guys come on 20 bucks you bring up me
and this again you volunteered this
information
don't make me the bad guy here you don't
get to play with the matches then get
upset when you get burned anyway we all
heard the rumor Steven Spielberg whoa
was maybe gonna direct Fantastic Four
and it leaked out in the Comic-Con
announcement and guess what it was one
big fake out that was hard to read and
there's no excuse because I'm the one
who wrote it
in honor of fake leaks and freak-a-leaks
quite frankly I want you all to give me
your best fake leaked Comic-Con
announcements okay we're all doing fake
leaks but this is a competition and it
will be decided by both the chat we'll
get to vote okay and I will have a vote
myself the winner
the winner of this contest with the best
fake leak coming out will have their
very own exclusive
four minute panel atomicon on Monday if
we raise the money we're assuming that
time you're really all in on Comic-Con
oh no I mean I just listen it's like
giving away money I don't have yet okay
yeah four minutes to say whatever you
want atomicon by the way we have 80 so
not impressed everyone we haven't even
gotten to one Chubby Bunny yet I was
ready I bought so many marshmallows from
CVS today that I could have made my own
Stay Puft Marshmallow Man cosplay and
instead everybody said you know what
these are off Brands
these are actually called marshmallows
and they're the opposite of Edibles they
make you they it's a night of horror
Thomas
is gonna be bigger than uh Spider Monday
I think yeah
Elijah Bowser hey just hit us okay I
believe their second contribution today
Elijah we owe you wow two different
contributions so this segment is thanks
to Elijah Bowser we thank you so much
it's time for chubby bunny let's see do
you have a trash can oh we don't know so
we gotta see what they're gonna vote for
yeah
please vote for Tom these marshmallows
Tommy's been craving these are these are
chubby bunny confessions so we will be
confessing something as we are playing
Chubby Bunny now I am such you guys know
all of the things I've done on this show
I I've it's not a confession about
something you have a show something you
did in the past no that's what we do I I
told them we did the our parents
basement yeah yeah I shop lifted some
dude wipes the other day not a sponsor
of the show but they could be I didn't
mean to I just accidentally didn't scan
them uh all right now uh dude watch
don't call in you want do we want to do
a fake yeah I'm gonna do my first okay
this is a fake Comic-Con the big one is
this week
see uh you guys know my relationship
with Brian Henson is on again off again
oh yeah we're pretty Rocky but yeah uh B
Henson and I got we chopped it up on
Saturday we got together on our jet skis
and we cruised out in Marina del Rey we
like to call the Satan's lap yeah that's
where we go by the power plant where
they're they're yeah all that uh nuclear
we spin around the powder plant we drink
an 18 pack of Coors Banquet beer uh Jess
you won the Chubby Bunny Challenge I'm
gonna finish my my leak and then we'll
begin Okay so
so that Jessica can have all attention
on her go ahead confession you guys you
remember when he said I bully him
lean into it Jessica be the villain I
don't like being the villain be the bad
guy I don't want to be the bad guy do we
have to count what how do we I'm trying
to think of like something I haven't
told you guys I'm an open book
um that's true I'll tell you one that is
a crime um yeah
I was 17 years old I didn't have my
license yet oh boy and I my friend's mom
just got over a breakup this is having a
really hard time
we took her car oh yeah that's good yeah
I really stick the knife in deeply we
put we got oatmeal like an oatmeal
Quaker oatmeal box we're gonna put milk
mustard mayonnaise oh jelly a bunch of
stuff in it we were like let's drive to
his house house
[Music]
and when we got there
we poured it all over his car yeah and
then the next morning it kind of feels
like snacking on marshmallows more than
that well and I got hard and it ruined
his car and my mom was like who did that
and then Rapunzel
roller
I think if I was keeping
John run away if you have to oh he's a
cute little
lipstick mark on that we're actually
gonna sell that Marshmallow with
Jessica's lipstick stain on it on Earth
okay come on we need another 100 so we
can keep doing this Chambers get
involved or hell maybe I'll confess to a
certain thing I did once that would be
punishable thank you
mm-hmm okay now I'm gonna go back so I
was doing what we call the Satan's lap
in Marina del Rey right around the power
plant that's where you speed around in
your jet ski you can't go lower than 40
miles an hour you crush an 18 pack of
Coors back with beer
Henson and I let's just put it this way
at one point I was straddling him on his
jet ski we were Towing mine and he
whispered in my ear Tarantino's
rebooting fraggles oh and I said what he
said you heard me Tarantino is doing an
R-rated version of Fraggle Rock he said
the dozers are not just gonna put
they're not just gonna take it laying
down this time if you know what I mean
they're going to get medieval yeah
they're gonna get it's gonna be nasty
and there will be and I have been told
that Marcellus Wallace's briefcase will
be returning as a through line in the
Tarantino Cinematic Universe love it
that's my leak the fraggles they eat the
things the Dozer yeah that's right and
guess what tastes delicious it ain't
gonna go so well for them oh and get a
ghost in a while okay well here's that
might be true I I think it's speechless
I think Henson was wasted obviously Jets
game was just talking out of his ass but
uh here's something that is true this is
confirmed I have a very good
I have a very good friend who worked the
secret wedding of uh uh uh a little Ben
Affleck wow Jennifer Lopez over the
weekend did that really happen uh it did
happen they got married she's taking his
name wow Jennifer Lynn Affleck that's
right uh but Affleck after this wedding
it's really changed his mind he's
returning to the Batman franchise wow I
love it but in this next
Affleck bat Fleck film okay he will be
playing Ben Affleck will be playing
Batman but he will also be playing The
Joker he's gonna play his own Joker I
know it sounds crazy double duty but the
most important part of all of this
that was right there
huge news is that JLo
will be playing Harley Quinn
whoa that's a good one that's definitely
keep it in the family that's so much
money you got it right into their
pockets right into their pockets can you
believe it I heard would you because I'm
in casting so I hear crazy stuff yeah
this is actually true sorry this is
crazy stuff all the time so uh you know
they're coming out with the Blues Clues
movie Yes where they're all like they're
bringing all the generations of Steve's
back well they're not all Steve's but
they're bringing them back I heard for
the movie that they're also going to be
bringing in their parents yeah so
because parents no no the dog not the
dog no the Steve and the newest Steve
which I think his name is Josh it's hard
because I was casting Steve not the
newest one Al Pacino's playing the
father no kidding the father oh okay
does Steve fanatically live at home or
is he out on his own he lives he's out
on his own lives alone lives alone lives
alone on his own with a dog but yes with
his dog but his dad for the movie is
going to be played by Al Pacino and the
narrator is Giancarlo Esposito here's
the male it never fails to make me want
to wag my tail when it comes I scream
and well it's middle time and your
head's all the way up
a great heat reference for all you kids
out there all right check out heat if
you haven't seen it happy 28th birthday
is he 28 years old probably older than
that
yeah yeah yeah
we're all uh racing towards death yeah
have Breakneck speed all right do you
have any I have any secret leaks I have
a leak that's coming out of Comic Con uh
I can't wait to see this news officially
get released this weekend at Comic-Con
but I heard from a little Hollywood
birdie that they are rebooting none
other than Beetlejuice Beetlejuice
beetlejuice is a reboot that's coming
and it's going to be starring none other
than everyone's favorite white man okay
Brian Cranston
Beetlejuice
it means everyone's favorite white man
is Keaton making an appearance he might
he might as Batman no okay as the role
that
the reason I didn't say he was my
favorite one
is a huge mine is oh wait nope nope nope
it's hard to have a favorite
vote in the chat right now we'll talk
about your favorite announcement yes
Tommy's the favorite wife that was
pretty good we've had some good uh polls
we read today we asked uh which are you
more excited for uh doing two or Peter
thinks in The Hunger Games you two 69
nice wow do you think Cameron had more
of a Sinister agenda no I believe him in
this interview
are you okay out there do you think
Kamala being a mutant is better than her
being in a human 77 said Mutant I think
we're all more happy with how the
mutants have turned out overall than the
Inhumans uh and should we hear the 90s
X-Men Rift every time someone has
declared a mutant or would that get old
69.
you guys we got 10 minutes left and I
gotta say I someone else has has to do
the Chubby Bunny Challenge figure out a
way to get there guys even if I have to
donate the last 20 myself
if a hundred of you donate a dollar
would be that's right if everybody just
starts getting a dollar now we get there
uh we've had some great super chats
today here for the cookies sent in a
Super Chat saying Jess please don't die
it's bad for your health
for it
was already bad yeah I can't wait for
the sweet Embrace of death uh Elijah
Bowser saying separating mutants and
humans are better and they share the
same concepts of powers the difference
is how the powers activate this models
Miss Marvel Powers activated because of
the bangle what if these trinkets are
how into it like so every mutant's gonna
need like a trinket to get it
I don't want my like a bunch of things
that's a big tie-in for Claire's I think
if Claire's jewelry oh yeah you're in on
this you get your ears pierced and
getting Powers
don't go to Claire's don't go anywhere
where they use a gun who's the guy who I
actually got my Prince Albert at
Claire's oh I'm sorry no buy a buy a man
name buy a man yeah you did go to Crazy
Claire you did he's a baker you did go
to class and take your penis out though
that is true I have I have whipped it
out in Claire's a few times Thomas what
give me the marshmallows
I need seven I need 67 more dollars if
you want me to cover this up okay
otherwise they're just confessions
alpaca great name had a a super check
get more abuse get Mobius and Loki on a
jet ski in season two if they do not do
the jet ski that show's done to me yeah
um John Lee said at a Super Chat how
many of you guys are going to be at
Comic-Con will you guys have any shows
after Marvel's panel on Saturday I don't
think are you gonna be there I'm not
gonna be there
Melina's gonna be wandering around down
there that's true if you get eyes on
Phillips send him a go I would just say
as a general shill for the company
uh I can't be a Comic Con this year
because I'm officiating a wedding but we
have we have have we are in plans and
having conversations about having a much
bigger comic convention presence moving
forward WonderCon Comic-Con next year La
Comic-Con and maybe a Comic Con near you
if you speak loudly enough we'll come on
down there and do our thing maybe the
break room we'll do a live show at your
convention you just gotta let us know I
got invited if you guys are going to
Crunchyroll Expo for that and Emerald
City Comic Con in Seattle in August not
bad so if you're going there you can
come harass me uh Archer also set in a
Super Chat saying shout out from the
716. thank you for being new hair and
all bills Mafia babies
buffalo baby Josh Allen here we go we're
so close that's the universe where they
actually win championships in Buffalo
that was so cool
I hate that that was good again
I'm more hurt now than anything hey we
guys we have a Discord and you should
join it because we started taking voice
questions questions on our Discord top
is the technology possible I think we
have one uh can we give it a shot I
think this is from here the here for the
cookies
I heard John uh so my question is the
last time we saw Thor before 11 Thunder
was at the end of end game when he still
had a prosthetic eye and somehow in love
and thunder he has his natural blue eye
grown back
are we supposed to assume that it just
regenerated and if so why did Odin's eye
never regenerate thanks love the show
thank you guys for doing what you do oh
thank you here for the cookies I really
hope you heard that uh at the home
audience otherwise it was just us
sitting here still for 30 seconds uh
this is a question of Thor's eye okay
obviously it was orange when he got the
prosthetic now it's blue again so
there's a couple options here one he got
a blue eye like just picked one up while
they're driving around in space right
that makes sense two two his real eye
grew back maybe
as Gordy and health Powers that's
gorgeous now that would be disturbing I
think when it's first happening and it's
like a tiny little pee I just imagine it
growing it's like when Deadpool was like
had the baby yeah yeah we had the baby
legs or whatever uh now with Odin I did
look up this a little bit so Odin in
both the comics and in like Norse
mythology has always had that eye patch
uh and the reason for this is he like
sacrifices his eye so he can learn about
Ragnarok from some soothsayer so that
he's he's ready for it yes
so so he knows what's going to go down
right now in the first Thor if you
recall Odin we see the battle with the
frost Giants Odin's got both of his eyes
Post Bow I saw that he's down and I post
battle all right good news that
marshmallow bowl is about to come into
play oh baby
so close uh stomach hurts because I've
just been eating them well you spit a
bunch of them back into a bowl I saw I'm
gonna go back and eat those after so I
already so I didn't like in the comics
in the north he donated sacrificed his
eyes so he could have this knowledge the
eye actually like comes back in the
comics as like its own sentient kind of
being in a very creepy way but in the
movies that they just didn't explain it
he's there this battle with the frost
Giants some sort of weapon does some
sort of damage that causes the eye to be
gone post battle we don't know how it
happens and it just stays that way I
don't know why Odin never healed do we
think do you think Thor healed or do you
think he just got a blue eye I thought
he healed I also didn't really pay too
much attention to his eye I was too busy
looking at that boy
Jessica in the theaters kept yelling
rewind it I said what's up there in the
booth hit pause she's in the rumble seat
she wasn't the rumble seat during the
weekend of Bernie against the whole time
now we are at another Chubby Bunny and
we've got very limited time so let's hit
that pole real quick to see who will be
Chubby Bunny confessing if we could
please stop sitting my dear
uh a couple other super and then someone
have the balls to donate a hundred
dollars in the last minute so that we
could do this twice I freaking dare you
uh Jonathan said at a Super Chat saying
do you think the MCU will draw more from
dawn of X instead of giving us another
intro and X-Men like past movies Donna
Vex was that the Post House of M stuff
I'm getting all my X-Men story lines
confused yeah uh I think that was like
when they all started coming back
because after House of them no New
Mutants were born for a while then a new
Mutant got born they sent her to the
future with cable uh and then she grew
up and she came back and she was like
Scott Summer's kid uh you guys remember
all these funny videos
you're Whispering into it I'm whispering
at you do we know anything about it
around here uh how am I wrong when
you're face deep in the market okay
Community marshmallows
the bad guy oh my God I just I wish we
weren't wearing the same shirt I just
want us to be honest a couple of
squirrels are doing great clearly this
is a great TV for everyone Jared B
wondering if anyone's gonna be a Fan
Expo Boston oh that maybe get empty to
go we'll make Mt go you can say hi to mg
uh hanging around around there uh jophie
is sending a Super Chat asking when's
the next time we see Kate Bishop ooh we
have talked about this a little bit I
think we were thinking echo echo echo
echo maybe She-Hulk maybe she got into
illegal trouble
she could buy her way out
that institutional viewers
okay the people demanded
I'm gonna tell a story also right now I
haven't always been the good guy you see
on this show the time in my life when I
was committing crimes stealing limes
let me think about something pretty bad
that I've done because I've done a lot
of really bad stuff
probably the worst thing you gotta keep
putting them in your mouth
it was still my mom's amazing
and load up a bunch of those Super
Soakers also stolen some cave light a
lot of Grand Theft Auto somebody's
stolen stuff it was water and then we
call people's sisters and tell them that
their brother was in trouble so they'd
come out in the front lawn
don't normally open the door
took 10 of them light them up
Drive
myself
[Music]
let me just soak them
we'd soak them with water
it was not nice
that's it
good job Tommy that's the chubby money
they've got us five five Mellows by my
count Jessica vested you I think I don't
need that I think I think you've been
best
uh uh yeah okay Bishop
probably I say okay uh you guys also
liked my fake Comic-Con announcement too
bad it was real uh get ready you were
mean to Ben Affleck as Batman and now
he's coming back and congratulations
if which we are on Pace we raised a
thousand dollars this week that's true
uh some some say I won some say I lost
you know either way uh uh I gotta do
comic Comic-Con baby uh we thank you all
for joining us for this Monday on the
break room Freaky Monday uh we hope your
Monday is going well as our Monday has
gone uh we'll be here all week live from
our very own break room uh when we're
not having a break we do the show uh uh
be sure to tune in all week thank you
Eric for being here today Tommy Jessica
thank you guys for being here uh make
sure you hit us up on Discord sending
some voice messages we'll be doing those
all week uh uh check out our Tick Tock
the underscore break room uh and be sure
to have a great rest of your day we love
you we appreciate you later skaters
we'll see you guys uh bye Breakers